immer mehr lkw auf deutschen straßen
großes problem aber auch großes geschäft
sebastian pufpaff ist einer der
erfolgreichsten deutschen logistik
unternehmer herr pufpaff stimmt das
eigentlich dass in deutschland immer
mehr fernfahrer über monate im lkw leben
ach kommen sie das wäre höchst illegal
nein so was mache ich nicht außerdem hat
der ogh gerade entschieden dass
lkw-fahrer ihre wöchentliche ruhezeit
ausdrücklich nicht im fahrzeug
verbringen dürfen und da halte ich mich
dran und das ist alles ganz klar
geregelt alle zwei wochen muss das
fahrzeug 45 stunden stehen und in dieser
zeit darf der fahrer nicht in der kabine
wo motto durchmachen mal zu das mussten
bisher weil sie selber darin
wahrscheinlich wieder katze mit reis
oder wieso er über 30 prozent der bei
uns eingesetzten lkw kommen mittlerweile
aus osteuropa in dem er an war die so
schön billig so hallo kommen sie
bezahlen mindestlohn also nicht den
deutschen
während ich großes nicht wir nehmen den
rumänischen zwei bis drei euro die
stunde
legal dh der gute rat hier verdient
weniger als ein liter diesel kostet aber
das sind ja genug sogar mit menschen ja
ich habe gehört viele trucker entladen
in ihrer vorgeschriebenen pausen zeit
ein lkw weil sie sonst ihre termine gar
nicht halten können
ja klar wenn die abladen fahren die ja
nicht es ist also eine fahrpause und
pausen finde ich die werden eh
überbewertet ja auch hier die sache mit
der übermüdung das wird immer hoch
gespielt ich habe mir da jetzt sehr viel
gelesen ausgedacht diesen hightech weg
assistenten das ist im prinzip eine hupe
die die jungen kopfschmerz und dann ist
das überhaupt kein problem weil wenn du
nach 23 stunden auf dem bock mal kurz
weg magst du wieder wach oder hier
lustige aufkleber die jugendfahrer
schläft gott segne die eu-osterweiterung
ich sage
ich hatte man polen er konnte während
der fahrt den sprit aus einem anderen
lkw absaugen
leider kann sie polen gar nicht mehr
nehmen
mittlerweile sind die polnischen fahrer
viel zu teuer geworden wir haben jetzt
liegt da sieht sind für die venus drauf
also steht in dem andere in ein zwei
jahren chinesen man vorhat das ist die
zukunft
zunächst ich habe sogar schon erste
tests gemacht mit einem guten dreierteam
chinesen wärst du nonstop shanghai
recklinghausen shanghai 23 jahre locker
ununterbrochen und zwei chinesen machen
fliegenden fahrerwechsel ohne anzuhalten
und der dritte chinese spielt natürlich
eine win win situation beziehungsweise
eigentlich eher eine ling ling situation
[Gelächter]
sebastian sofort voll damen und herren
[Applaus]